it almost feels like the secret sauce of
success as you scale is trimming down
and simplifying things and so what i
realized at that point was like
okay i'm on youtube now i'm doing these
podcast episodes i'm also on tik tok and
instagram and and i have like clients
like it just felt like a lot and i
realized that that was also what was
kind of potentially preventing me from
scaling up my time
what gets measured gets improved when
you decide to become laser focused on
your youtube analytics you can start to
see improvements in your views your
subscribers and even your profits from
youtube but which ones should you
actually look at which ones matter and
how do you know if you are winning well
in today's episode we are continuing the
conversation with our friend and fellow
creator vanessa lau and she breaks down
the five analytics she used to get over
25
million views on her channel my name is
heather torres and you are listening to
the think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business today's episode is
brought to you by our free
youtube 1k challenge
this is a live and highly interactive
challenge where you will learn how to
get your first 1000 subscribers and earn
your first 1000 on youtube
you'll get the new strategies and learn
exactly what's working on youtube right
now and we're gonna be doing free
youtube trainings every single day with
actionable steps challenges for you to
do so that you can watch your youtube
views and subscribers grow don't miss
the opportunity to jumpstart your
youtube channel and you can save your
spot for the tube 1k challenge by going
to tube 1k
dot
right now now today's episode is a
continuation of the conversation that
sean cannell and fellow youtube creator
vanessa lau had last week here on the
podcast and she walked through what
happened when her youtube channel
stopped working now if you've not been
introduced to vanessa lau yet you must
go and watch her she's an amazing
youtube creator who started by working
in a corporate environment hating her
job and now creating a successful
multiple seven-figure online business
with over 500 000 subscribers and 25
million views on youtube she's building
a thriving community as well as a team
in her home office in canada so last
week sean and vanessa really talked
about the emotional side of that dip
what happens when your youtube channel
stops working and what should you do to
get yourself back on track and in
today's episode we're walking through
the five analytics that vanessa looked
at when she started to see that dip her
youtube channel breaking and how she was
able to overcome that and also the
analytics she was looking at in her
business to see was she really failing
or was this just something happening on
youtube after that conversation all come
back on and we'll get into a couple of
the action steps for you to take away
from today's episode
[Music]
what are the analytics that you actually
pay attention to
and how do you measure
success on youtube but in a second i
also then want to kind of extrapolate
out and talk about
how you measure success in your business
overall because while they're connected
they're actually
they're not they're not the same thing
there there's a two entirely different
like you know how are we keeping score
if you will but let's focus first on
analytics for you what are maybe the one
two three seven analytics that you
really like to look at that you kind of
gauge as whether or not your channel is
making an impact or not
yeah well i try to keep things simple
but before i answer that i think that it
ties into your second question i think
that for those listening it's really
important to understand why you started
a youtube channel because everyone's got
different goals so for example like i
have a business where i sell like
digital programs and all of that and
youtube is a way for me to get more
traffic and more leads to my business
for you if you're like an influencer and
you're using youtube as a way to push
like affiliate marketing then like your
goals might be different there so that's
just one preface we can dive into that a
bit more but for me personally
i i like to keep things simple
so i just look at that youtube funnel
that's uh when you go into your creator
studio you go to analytics you hit reach
and then you've got that funnel i really
love the new creator studio layout even
though it tells you to your face how
you're doing and sometimes it can be
painful and it hurts but i do appreciate
how it's laid out because i think now
more than ever more than at least two
years ago it's actually a lot easier to
understand what's actually going on in
your channel so when i talk about that
funnel when you hit that reach button
you're gonna see this like upside down
triangle almost and it basically tells
you like the top five metrics that
youtube actually like cares about so the
first one is impressions how many times
are people actually seeing your video
being served to them whether it's in
search homepage whatever else and then
it goes down to your click-through rate
you know of those times that they saw
your video you know on the internet how
many people actually clicked it so i
think that's really important to gauge
because now you can understand whether
or not your thumbnails your title or
maybe your topic is actually effective
then it funnels down to i believe like
views
so of those people who clicked it how
many people actually like watched a good
like watched your video and not just
clicked it and left like immediately
and then afterwards it funnels down to
view duration so
after you get the view you obviously
want someone to watch your whole video
or as much of the video as possible so
view duration is really important
because you know if you're spending
a bunch of time creating one hour long
videos and maybe you're pouring money
into it and like you have video editors
or maybe you're actually like spending
more time in your workflow than you need
to to create videos that are an hour
long but when you look at your analytics
and you see that people are only
watching
10 of your video then you're probably
either wasting a lot of money or time or
some sort of resource you're not really
optimizing it there and that data is
going to be very important for you to
see that or even let's say if you you do
um maybe you're a business owner and you
have call to actions within your video
and maybe at the end of the video is
only when you start talking about your
product or whatever else or whatever you
want to promote and then you notice that
most people don't even get to the end of
the video
then you're you're not meeting your goal
as a business owner of getting more
leads to your business are you and so i
really like looking at view duration and
then um the last thing after view
duration is okay of all the people that
watch your videos what's your watch time
you know what's the total amount of
hours that you've accumulated on your
channel because
you know even like especially if you're
listening to this and you're not
monetized you know that in order to get
monetize youtube looks at how much watch
time you've got and how many subscribers
you have you everyone kind of knows that
watch time is pretty important in the
eyes of youtube and so
again luckily the creator studio makes
it so easy for you everything i'm saying
is literally like in one page for you to
see
and those are typically the top five
that i pay attention to because to me it
feels like that's what youtube pays
attention to
that was like a nice mini master class
there those five metrics if you can
if you can also raise up your
click-through rate and you can raise up
your average view duration um then
youtube is saying hey those are kind of
the two metrics that are going to
determine if we give you more
impressions and you keep your eyes on
those metrics then theoretically your
channel will continue to grow uh you
know a couple other ones that i think
can also be interesting is not just how
many top line views is your channel
getting but how many unique viewers are
you getting a month or how many
returning viewers versus new viewers are
you getting um and then on a macro i use
vid iq when i'm doing channel reviews to
just actually look at
the dashboard and they just have three
that they kind of overlay for any even
if you will somebody else's channel a
competitor's channel a stranger's
channel somebody's channel you want to
study it just says how many subscribers
in the last 38 days how oh 28 how many
views and how many uploads and i think
even measuring the correlation of
you know if it's no new uploads
then you might have your performance go
down if you upload four videos in a
month
great if you upload eight maybe you'll
double your view sometimes we say you'll
double your views if you double your
uploads of course that correlation
is not one-to-one because it might be a
lot of old videos in your library but
all these different levers can of course
influence whether our views are up or
down whether youtube feels broken or not
to us but i do want to pivot now because
the health of your youtube channel quote
unquote
may not actually
signify the health of your business and
i do think that a lot of youtube
creators can become myopic
by actually looking at what
could be vanity metrics
because if you are not looking at your
profit and loss as a business owner
essentially or your income statement
or
things that might be also harder to
measure but
your culture of your team once you start
building a team
your meant your own health you know it'd
be like it'd be one thing how i uploaded
20 videos this month and almost killed
myself so of course there's like all
kinds of almost iq eq metrics and i do
think that we need to be thinking a lot
bigger when we define success as a
youtube entrepreneur a content
entrepreneur so you alluded to that dive
into that a little bit in terms of maybe
how you measure success in your business
overall
yeah i look at sales like because that's
what keeps the lights on right like i've
got a team i'm also like even if i
didn't have a team in let's say i have
um my youtube channel i'm also pouring a
lot of money over time on this channel i
do want to make sure that i make it back
in some way and so for me with my
programs i look at you know how many
people have we actually enrolled this
month how many sales have we made what's
the recurring revenue on that um those
are things that i measure as a business
owner and profit right and that's kind
of what triggered you know in the
beginning of this interview you asked me
why i made that video that's when i
realized something wasn't adding up
because it almost felt like i was
spending more money on my youtube
channel and i wasn't seeing like an
increase in enrollments because of those
extra additional investments that i made
on my channel it's not like i was seeing
an increase i was just kind of
maintaining the same so if i'm spending
so much on my channel and like my sales
are more or less the same
then i'm eating into my profit
and that's not making sense and when i
looked at my data and my stats i'm like
wait the videos that were more scrappy
and had like i poured less like you know
money on it and i just showed up as
myself and i just shared the dang
content you know i actually can lower my
my my cost here and if i even if i
maintain the sales at least my profit's
better right and so those are things
that i i really pay attention to um to
truly measure my success in business
because again
um
there's no mission without margin is
what i like to say like if you have a
big mission as a content creator or as a
business owner actually you want to
change the lives of so many people i
think that's i think at the heart of it
that's why most content creators start
being on youtube is because they want to
share the things that they know about
they care about people and if you are
if you're lucky enough that you're able
to monetize that and you're also able to
get paid from that i think that's
awesome but you have to realize that in
order for you to feel your mission you
need to have margin
you need to have money coming in so that
you can expand your team and create more
content because eventually you might
outgrow your own little one-person
operation
and you're not able to let's say let's
say you work with clients or let's say
you sell products or whatever else
you're not able to do everything just
yourself and if you really want to grow
your business you got to have the money
to be able to do that
i love that and
i'm curious i'm sure listeners are maybe
wondering too they're they're probably
trying to budget for their channel some
are doing everything themselves right
now so it's sweat equity they're
shooting they're editing
they're
really keeping it lean and mean maybe
trying to get
some income um coming in so they can
reinvest you have a whole business model
and a business bigger than youtube so
you see this investment into youtube
maybe into gear or team but actually
break it down for us i'm curious
what like what are maybe even some
numbers you were thinking about what
what were you devoting towards youtube
and then you hit this thing to say okay
now i need to determine if this return
on investment was worth it and again i
guess we ultimately are all asking is
the return on investment of either one
of two things our time and we probably
all have to invest our time because even
you got to be on camera create the
content but also then money you're like
well i'm going to hire an editor or
maybe try to speed up workflow or try to
improve my production quality so going
into this season what was the investment
you were calculating
so it really started with my podcast
actually because what i want to do
differently with my podcast was i wanted
to make it into a video form and post it
on youtube so it almost felt like i was
doubling my uploads on youtube and
as a result of that because i wanted the
videos to have like all the fanciness
pretty much the same type of quality
almost that i had for my youtube videos
it almost felt like i was doubling
my investment every month so my invoice
let's say
would double because i doubled the
uploads right and so there was like a
number that i could see that clearly
changed from before and that made sense
to me at the time but then as i started
uploading i realized wait a second like
my sales or my enrollments aren't
necessarily doing any better
the views aren't necessarily like
contributing much more and also when i
surveyed my audience most of them
weren't even paying attention to the
videos
and so i had enough data to tell me like
oh okay this might not be working out
now another thing too and the reason why
it was
clear to me that though at least the way
that i was doing it wasn't right um was
i tested it for at least three months so
that's one thing that i think is really
important for listeners to know is when
you are implementing something new
you don't want to like judge the result
based off of like the first three videos
and like okay i'm gonna stop this
strategy because it's not working you
know it might be work it might work but
you just need more time with it um and
so for me i think i i did at least three
months like three to six months almost
of content um and still not seeing a
lift in much
and i did surveys and i polled people
and i asked them and it wasn't a
considerable amount of like it just
didn't make that big of a difference if
that makes sense and so that's when i
knew like okay something's not
not adding up here and i have to either
like
change the way that i'm doing the
workflow maybe instead of making all the
videos superly edited i like reduce that
or maybe instead of thinking a two-hour
long podcast episode or a two-hour long
video is what's going to be great on
youtube maybe i shorten it so that would
work well um but even after a few months
of testing it just didn't necessarily
feel like that was where my focus needed
to be at the time
um and also like something that i've
learned as i've grown as a content
creator and as a business owner at the
same time
is
i find that it almost feels like the
secret sauce of success as you scale is
trimming down and simplifying things and
so what i realized at that point was
like okay i'm on youtube now i'm doing
these podcast episodes i'm also on tik
tok and instagram and all these other
things and i'm running a business and
i'm doing like all and and i have like
clients like it just felt like a lot and
i realized that that was also what was
kind of potentially preventing me from
scaling up my time
and um it almost felt like i wasn't
listening to my own advice that i would
share with other people is like if you
have all your eggs in all these baskets
you can't really go all in
on one thing
and when i did my surveys and i think
that this this feels like a very
elementary tip
but
i think at any stage in business whether
you are starting out when you got zero
or whether you're at six figure seven
figures eight figures you should always
have a checkpoint with your audience and
like do some market research like we
launched a survey with our entire
audience both our customers and our
non-customers and we were i was able to
learn so much about why they
how they even get into my world and like
what platforms are actually moving the
needle uh what are they actually paying
attention to what actually led them to
buying and becoming a customer later on
and what i found was an overwhelmingly
amount was instagram and youtube
um and so i realized at that point when
i had the data i was like this is my
bread and butter why am i trying to like
do this whole podcast thing right now or
why am i trying to like do this whole
tick tock thing right now or doing all
these different things you know maybe i
should stick with my bread and butter
and really make that really great uh
whether that's the content being better
whether that's i don't know more
frequent uploads or just being more
attentive to it um those were kind of
the main learning lessons that i i
realized when it came to just evaluating
what was worth the effort and what
wasn't
well i hope that that conversation
sparked some action steps for you to
take and the number one action step i'm
going to ask you to do think media fam
is get inside of your youtube studio i
know there are a lot of numbers
happening a lot of tabs you can click on
but you starting to get really familiar
with what matters most on your channel
is going to be the difference of you
winning and you're losing you've got to
know what are the winning numbers look
like and where do you need to improve so
pick one analytic to look at over the
next 30 days and try and increase that
maybe it's just in the watch time so are
you making videos where people are
watching longer your average view
duration or maybe it's the click-through
rate do you want to get a higher
click-through rate i want you to pick
one analytic that you are going to
actually look at for the next 30 days
and try to improve now i want to thank
you if you have been a part of the think
media fam here on the podcast over the
last several months and year and i want
to say thank you to all of you who are
brand new this might be your first time
listening to the podcast and when i say
welcome you are in the best place to
grow your influence on youtube and i
haven't asked that is if you can go and
rate and review the podcast over on
itunes it helps us so much if you do
that we have over 400 now and i'm trying
to get that number to 600 so if you can
help me do that it would be amazing i'm
going to feature today on the podcast w
h main
left this review over there and said the
podcast to listen to if you want to grow
this podcast is a practical no-nonsense
guide to being successful on youtube it
is packed with interviews and
information from people who are actually
doing it every week there is something
new to think about and apply to your
business think media's podcasts are easy
to listen to engrossing funny and
entertaining all at the same time you
don't want to miss one video if you care
about your youtube channel and nope no
one paid me to say this it's the
absolute truth yes no one paid him to
say that and i'm so excited that he did
because this is what he said that really
sparked me he said
that every week there is something new
to think about and apply to your
business
we want you to be creating a thriving
business with your youtube channel it
starts with making your first video but
we want you to be thinking about the big
picture how can you turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business the creator economy is
booming and you are in the right place
to learn exactly how to maximize that
for what you want in your life thank you
so much for being a part of what we're
doing here at think media and we will
catch you in the next episode bye are
you ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
you